joining me now is woody johnson former
u.s ambassador to the united kingdom and
co-owner of the new york jets uh woody
you had a wonderful relationship with
the queen
uh we're showing some of the pictures of
the two of you now
tell us about her and as you got to know
her
uh well the first time i met her
you know you give your each ambassador
gives her your letters your credentials
and then you have a short conversation
uh and at that meeting which is
which is pretty exciting at uh
buckingham palace
i asked her if we could have dinner
together and she could bring some of her
friends and she said i'd love to
but let's have your friends instead
so some of those pictures that you see i
think are are part of that evening so
about you know a few months later
she came over and
i got to know her and see her among a
few of the friends that she brought as
well and uh you could see
just all the things you talked about the
resolve the
humor uh yeah you got to be on your toes
you had to be on your toes with her she
was very very quick
she had incredible memory uh
on almost any subject so
and woody you know i was her yeah
her relationship with yuge got to know
your family
and president trump um i know because i
spoke to him about it
he just adored her and it looks like she
kind of adored him
well i've known uh donald trump you know
former president trump for 40 years
and i've never seen him as excited about
anything
maybe with the exception of his wife
uh to meet
to meet the queen and have a
conversation particularly
there was a lunch before the state
dinner which was very funny but the
dinner itself he had he told me this not
the details
but 45 minute discussion with her
majesty that he said was
probably the highlight of his
presidential career
uh just that was the impact she had on
on our president
but also i don't i imagine all world
leaders that met her i know mike pompeo
met her and the people of the
administration and they were all wowed
by this
pledge at 14 to serve her entire life
long or short
the people and she did she uh her two
days before she died
she had a meeting with liz trust the new
prime minister
and boris johnson the outgoing prime
minister
so to the very end she served and
just one example
what do you think woody
will change
with charles as king
well i think you know
the good news about
about her life and what she's done is it
it lays out a pretty good uh path
forward you know she changed with the
times
she has a lot of young people around her
uh so she gets different points of view
and i think joel king charles now will
will do the same i've met i've met him
and the president's met him we like him
and uh very smart and i think he'll do
an excellent job
woody the end of an era though with uh
queen elizabeth's passing i mean we had
gorbachev die what a week or so ago
those are kind of the last two
very influential people of the 20th
century still alive i believe other
jimmy carter obviously but i think
elizabeth and and
gorbachev in their own ways had profound
influence
well and there's really nobody like
uh elizabeth ii there's really no
equivalent in the world
uh
in my in my eyes and the president's
eyes said she's never done anything
wrong
she's had seven decades in service plus
all those years before that
and um
that's pretty good i mean it's not as
good as laura yeah laura's you laura but
you know that's a pretty good record
yeah now
i remember getting your christmas card
though woody and seeing you with the
queen i'm like okay you win like winnie
has nobody has the christmas card it's a
picture of you yeah you won you'll know
but you were so touched by her and uh
getting to know her and i was so
grateful that you were able to come on
tonight to share some of those memories
so what a pleasure
woody thank you so much thank you so
much thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else